bonjour ma beauté petit réveil ce kit
[ __ ]
oui la balle à quoi faire il sait
pourquoi faire ça fait depuis septembre
qu'on met l'argent de côté
comment on va trouver tout ce qu'ils
mangent en sait rien on est les seuls
planter la priverait ras le cul te
pourrir dans les amphis c'est l'occasion
de voir le monde s'est tu
c'est fini la loose on peut faire on
fait comme si c'était un jeu vidéo
réserves en or à maslacq
3 je changeais tournée épique il ya des
petits qu on vive la vie avec attend et
qui toi je m'appelle aliens pourquoi tu
es là vous ai vu dans la salle
vous aviez l'air sympa allez quoi c'est
quoi c'est terrifiant là je suis pété de
thunes j'ai commis pour les crimes du
monde
je te connais pas je ne sais pas ce que
tu ne bosses et faut que tu nous laisses
tranquille
un pressentiment jours sur 7 partir au
spring break vous avez pété les plombs
c'est un mois tous âges
après une brève escale
alors l'inesss aux ennemis et menaces
qui pèsent sur lui